цей закон називають історичним німецький
парламент ухвалив документ який скорочує
і спрощує отримання німецького паспорта
для іноземців розповідаємо про ключові
зміни претендувати на німецький паспорт
можна буде вже через 5 років проживання
в Німеччині донині було вісім Якщо
людина має так звані особливі
інтеграційні досягнення то зможе
податися на громадянство вже за три роки
досі було
шість новий закон який ухвалили Але який
ще не набув чинності надає можливість
натуралізації за роки якщо будуть
виконані певні
умови це означає що якщо українські
біженці приїхали до Німеччини у 2022
році то теоретично вони можуть подавати
заявку з 25-го але звісно вони повинні
виконати спеціальні
вимоги особливій інтеграці
досягнення наприклад це високий рівень
німецької мови активна участь у
волонтерстві або значні професійні
досягнення особливим досягненням буде
наприклад сертифікат С1 про знання
німецької мови Це означає що людина
виконує вимоги щодо мовних навичок і
навіть більше вона довела що прагне
якнайшвидше
інтегруватисяще догнення здобуття освіти
в Німеччині а також якщо ви працюєте на
громадських засадах у німецьких
організаціях берете активну участь у
їхній
діяльності звісно рішення ухвалюватиме
конкретний чиновник є тут особливе
інтеграційне досягнення чи
немає ще одна ключова зміна охочі
отримати німецький паспорт не повинні
будуть в від первинного громадянства
наприклад українського раніше зберегти
український паспорт можна було тільки як
виняток робота в
Німеччині іноземці які бажають отримати
німецький паспорт повинні самі себе
забезпечувати що це означає для
українських біженців які отримують
допомогу від
держави добре якщо претенденти на
громадянство мають безстроковий трудовий
договір
держава повинна пересвідчити що люди
фінансово забезпечені тобто самі стоять
на ногах а не знову подаватимуть заявки
на отримання соцвиплат після того як
набудуть
громадянство експертка наводить приклад
Якщо ви влаштувалися на роботу місяць
тому і маєте трудовий договір на півроку
то це суттєво зменшить шанси на
отримання паспорта найкраще мати
безстроковий трудовий договір тобто
довести що матимете робо місце в
майбутньому
діти якщо хоча б один із батьків
іноземців прожив у Німеччині 5 років то
його Діти зможуть отримати німецьке
громадянство коли дитина стане
повнолітньою Їй більше не доведеться
обирати між німецьким громадянством і
тим яке вона успадкувала від
батьків кому не даватимуть
громадянство громадянами Німеччини не
зможуть стати антисемти расисти та інші
особи які зневажають людську гідність
паспорти не надаватимуть тим хто не
визнає рівноправність чоловіків і жінок
чоловіки які мають кількох дружин теж не
зможуть стати німецькими
громадянами чому німецький паспорт стане
доступнішим населення Німеччини старішає
робочих рук бракує німецький уряд
намагається заохотити пере лятися в
країну фахівців ізза
кордону міністрка внутрішніх справ Ненсі
фезер каже що новий закон має
стимулювати інтеграцію мігрантів у
німецьке суспільство а не створювати їм
перешкоди Ми хочемо щоб люди які вже
давно є частиною нашого суспільства
також брали участь у формуванні країни
демократичним
шляхом закон Про громадянство ухвалили у
другому читанні тепер його має схвалити
бундесрад орга що представляє федеральні
землі потім закон підпише президент
Німеччини після цього документ стане
чинним експерти Припускають що після
набуття чинності нового Закону близько 8
мільйонів людей зможуть претендувати на
німецький паспорт черги у відомствах у
справах іноземців можуть стати ще
довшими ніж
досі